[Musique]
183 euros c'est la somme que les
soignants du service de soins infirmiers
à domicile ssiad du centre hospitalier
de rambouillet réclame à l'appel de la
cgt et de force ouvrière
une cinquantaine de personnels s'est
réuni jeudi devant l'hôpital pour
montrer leur mécontentement
cette somme correspond à l'augmentation
que le personnel hospitalier a reçu en
cette fin d'année 2020 dans le cadre du
ségur de la santé seul bémol le srd en a
été exclu si nous sommes là aujourd'hui
c'est pour se mobiliser pour le siad qui
a été victime du ségur qui n'aura pas
d'augmentation lui contrairement à tout
le reste de l'établissement
voilà elle se mobilise chaque jour au
domicile pour maintenir les patients
chez eux
et voilà mes collègues et soignantes ont
et ont dû aller en renfort pendant la
première vague à l'ehpad du centre
hospitalier de rambouillet à l'ehpad
dhabi et là on est onze est bien partie
du centre hospitalier de rambouillet et
là on n'en fait plus partie
une colère d'autant plus importante que
la deuxième vague de kobe de 19 et bien
là et que le personnel soignant est une
nouvelle fois mis à contribution
selon la cgt 9 lits sur seize en
réanimation seraient occupés par des
patients qu'aux vide il ya des endroits
où ça devient tellement tendue qu'on ne
peut plus à s'arrêter ne serait ce que
pour ceux pour se mobiliser mais c'est
une situation qui est très critique dans
dans l'ensemble des services
hospitaliers rendu du département élus
et du pays à croire que la première
vague n'a pas servi de leçon
parce que c'est toujours aussi chaotique
mais avec des personnels de plus en plus
exposés de plus en plus épuisés et donc
forcément des personnels de plus en plus
touché le centre hospitalier de
rambouillet est un exemple parmi tant
d'autres dans les yvelines au 6 novembre
627 patients sont hospitalisés dont 73
en réanimation